[Musique]
l'entretien politique avec 10 muller
maire d'epône bonjour monsieur le maire
bonjour mais bonjour à tous vos
téléspectateurs alors et poneys c'est
d'une commune des yvelines de 6550
habitants très précisément je crois
peut-être un peu plus ce qui est dans le
mantois c'est-à-dire de non loin de
manque la ville de mantes la ville et
demande la jolie vous avez été largement
réélu dès le premier tour des élections
municipales en mars dernier c'est votre
deuxième mamba qu'est ce qui vous plaît
dans le métier de mère on dit souvent
que les maires sont les seuls élus qui
ben peuvent voir concrètement les les ce
pouvoir ne veut voir naître
concrètement les décisions qu'ils
prennent est ce que c'est ça qui vous
plaît alors je crois que c'est surtout
le l'envi d'être au contact avec avec
mes concitoyens
j'ai toujours eu dans ma vie différents
engagements avec les parents d'élèves
avec dans le domaine sportif et je crois
que c'est surtout l'envi de de faire en
sorte que autour de moi les choses se
passent bien et pau nous donne la
possibilité de nous exprimer au niveau
de nos réalisations pour aller dans ce
sens-là
alors avant d'aborder les projets s'ils
sont nombreux d'ailleurs pour votre
ville on peut citer deux choses qui sont
assez connus ou qui devrait l'être
encore plus peut-être d'abord le top de
l'amitié qui est un monument historique
et dont on dit qu'il serait le plus
ancien temple masson et qu'il aurait
même été dessiné par le peintre david
c'est bien ça alors c'est bien ça c'est
l' architecture qui a été dessiné par le
peintre david c'est à petit temple et
qui s'inscrit dans dans ce qu'est la
ville d'epône qu'on peut caractériser
par trois points à savoir une ville
entre histoire nature et modernité donc
là on parle de l'aspect historique
effectivement
lors de la révolution nous avions la
chance d'avoir comme com comment dire
comme comme noble au niveau de la ville
hérault de séchelles déroute seychelles
qui sentant le vent de la révolution
venir s'est rapproché un petit peu des
révolutionnaires danton robespierre
saint-just et il avait également des
relations avec benjamin franklin qui est
à l'époque ambassadeur des états unis en
frein en france et il faisait il
organiser parce qu'on était à portée de
carros de versailles ici iphone et
l'organiser fréquemment des fêtes et
aidé lors de ces fêtes ils ont décidé de
construire ce temple de l'amitié
franco-américaine
effectivement les deux est un maçon
c'est aujourd'hui le plus ancien temple
maçonnique connu en france en france et
puis deuxième chose que les gens ne
savent peut-être pas c'est que c'était
punk aînés vous font la constitution de
la vème république
mais même la première c'est la
république qu'est né à épauler
république est née à epône dans la
mesure où à eu à l'époque hérault de
séchelles avec saint-just danton et
robespierre
on travaillait dans les jardins du
château d'epône à la mise en place de la
constitution l'an 2 qui est la première
constitution de la république française
une fois sa mis en place les années les
années se sont passées et le général de
gaulle à l'époque en 58 quand il
réfléchissait à mettre en place ce la
république la constitution de la vème
république a demandé à son premier
ministre michel debré de se mettre au
vert pour y réfléchir à cette nouvelle
constitution et à l'époque le
propriétaire de ce château était en
relation vite michel debruyne rennes
heureux des relations amicales et il
s'est dit je veux venir avec quelques
ministres iphone pour réfléchir à cette
nouvelle constitution de la constitution
de la vème république donc à double
titre et poney le berceau france de la
république et à epône alors parlons un
peu comme de l'actualité de votre ville
peut-être la première c'est que le rer b
devrait arriver à epône joue en 2024
est-ce que ça va être un bouleversement
pour pour vous et pour les époux noah
alors bouleversement je sais pas mais
toujours est il que c'est un élément
important de l'évolution des villes qui
sont situés sur cette ligne e la ligne
eole est effectivement epône va être une
des gares de cette nouvelle ligne donc
le fait d'avoir des relations simplifiée
avec la capitale et en particulier avec
la défense également ce n'est pas sans
savoir que la ligne e va être la ligne
la plus connectée des du réseau parisien
donc ça va permettre d'avoir des
échanges simplifié à la fois pour les
entreprises qui veulent voler ni veulent
venir s'installer à epône ou pour les
époux noah pour aller travailler au delà
de nos frontières
donc effectivement c'est c'est un
élément clé du développement de la ville
d'epône et d'ailleurs nous sommes en
train de travailler avec mézières parce
que la gare c'est l'iphone p ierre de
ville qui ce qui se jouxtent et nous
sommes en train de travailler avec évier
et mézières et vente effectivement
également avec gps et au la communauté
urbaine grand paris seine et oise sur la
mise en place d'un nouveau quartier gare
et c'est un des projets phares de cette
nouvelle mandature alors très rapidement
parce qu'il reste peu de temps mais je
voudrais quand même l'abordez vous
disiez que ce qui vous est mis dans le
métier de mère c'était le rapport avec
avec vos concitoyens justement vous êtes
vous avez mis en place sorte de
concertation participative de faire
participer des citoyens aux décisions et
notamment sur le développement durable
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit mot alors
disons-le assez on est au bo béaba de
ceux de cette politique qu'on essaie de
mettre en place sur cette deuxième de
mandature même si depuis un certain
temps déjà nous travaillons avec dans
l'esprit le développement durable mais
je crois qu'on a pour mission tous tous
les tous les élus de france et de
navarre on a pour mission de faire en
sorte que que demain puisse être un
moment de bien vivre pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens
et ça ça passe forcément par la volonté
de protection de la nature la protection
de du climat et donc l'idée c'est de
mettre en place à la fois une comment
dire un esprit de deux consultations
avec la mise en place d'une écologie
positive et plus que des actions qu'on
va te faire défiler les unes après les
autres
plus de créer dans nos actions un état
d'esprit qui est dans le lidl dans le
développement durable jassaint 2,2 de
consensus sur ce qui pourrait être
l'avenir
mes côtés pour vous donner pour vous
donner un exemple nous avons rassemblé
un certain nombre d'entreprises
il ya peu de temps et on a décidé de
créer un éco label c'est à dire de faire
en sorte de demander à voir des
entreprises sur quelques critères qui
vont dans le bon sens par rapport au
développement durable de s'intégrer à
cette démarche et la ville sicilienne et
vire notamment ils sont volontaires et
qui met cela en place dans leur
entreprise de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse nous communiquer sur le fait
qu'en epône il y à des entreprises qui
travaillent avec moi comme préoccupation
le développement durable
très bien mais ça fait partie des grands
projets de votre ville on aura je pense
l'occasion d'en reparler fait une petite
présentation de d'epône et de vous
heureux de son maire dit muller merci
infiniment
je vous en prie mais il reste beaucoup à
dire
[Musique]